[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si notre belelle amour devait être un
mirage dans l'immense désert dont le
sable et le
thint
gardons en pour la vie la Chimérie qui
mage de ce qui été sous un ciel moins
brûlant vrai que l'on sait m'affirmer je
ne
[Musique]
l'OSE quand je pense à ses jours l'on se
laisse
[Musique]
froid à ces jours où
l'en obscurcit toute choses ni la terre
ni le ciel ne me parle de
toi je consulte mon cœur mais il est
capricieux et ton cœur qui tant au
suscité son émoin le laissera tout à
l'heure et le laissera quoi
et puis je me souviens de ses jours
àieu
oh notre bel amour au ciel pur ce
fiance et je ferme les
yeux blotti dans ma
confiance je m'assoupie heureux et
souvent j'y
repense et souvent j'y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
repense